[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren
deutschland steht vor einer rezession
keine einfache konjunkturdelle sondern
ein handfester rückgang der
wirtschaftsleistung
die exporte brechen ein mit
zweistelligen verlusten in einige
wichtige aus vorländer china
großbritannien und russland besonders
betroffen automobilindustrie und
maschinenbau
das rückgrat unserer industriellen
produktion und damit unseres wohlstands
die meldungen über massive
stellenstreichungen in tragenden
unternehmen und schlüsselbranchen reißen
nicht ab
das wirtschaftswachstum stagniert das
bruttoinlandsprodukt ist im zweiten
quartal 2009 10 sogar geschrumpft
damit sind wir im vergleich der übrigen
eu und euro mitgliedstaaten schlusslicht
die krise kommt nicht die krise ist
bereits da die nächste rezession
weder ein vom himmel gefallen das
schicksal sein noch das werk böser
mächte
sie ist in erster linie hausgemacht die
schwierigkeiten die deutsche wirtschaft
und damit das ganze land hineinrutscht
sind die folge ihrer verhängnisvollen
und wirtschaftsfreundlichen politik
einer im kern grün einer im kern grün
sozialistischen ideologie die unser land
ruiniert und seiner zukunftsfähigkeit
beraubt diese regierung trägt die
verantwortung für die demontage der
autoindustrie durch klimaschutz mann und
e auto planwirtschaft sie ruinieren
unser land mit der absurden idee
gleichzeitig aus atomenergie und
kohleverstromung aufsteigen zu können
und zu einem fiktiven datum in nicht
allzu ferner zukunft typische
planwirtschaft das land co2 neutral zu
machen muss man sich mal vorstellen
das ist absolut grotesk und das ist ein
ökonomischer und naturwissenschaftlicher
nonsens der uns jetzt schon die höchsten
stromkosten in europa beschert
hunderttausende haushalte von
geringverdienern und mittelschicht in
existenzielle bedrängnis bringt die
versorgungssicherheit gefährdet und
energieintensive industrie nach und nach
aus deutschland vertreibt
vorgeblicher klimaschutz ist nichts
anderes als ein monströses
deindustrialisierung programm verbunden
mit veritabler arbeitsplatzvernichtung
sie verschwänden aber milliarden um
imaginierte weltuntergänge in ferner
zukunft abzuwenden
sie lassen sich von fragwürdigen
lobbyisten wie die deutsche umwelthilfe
aus meiner sicht gehört diese lobby
organisationen verboten am gängelband
führen und zerstören dafür die
grundlagen unseres wohlstands in unsere
fähigkeit die ganz realen und drängenden
herausforderungen der kommenden
jahrzehnte zu meistern
zum beispiel die unbewältigten folgen
der ungeregelten migration in die
sozialsysteme und die kriminalstatistik
ist weiß schon warum sie so quietschen
der frühere bundesnachrichtendienst chef
august hanning spricht von mehr als zwei
millionen überwiegend jungen männern
dieser 2015 eingewandert sind und die
nächste welle steht schon vor der tür
die bilder aus westport sind ein
menetekel der türkei deal an denen sie
sich ja so gerne und so lange geklammert
haben ist gescheitert die balkanroute
ist offen
sie verschließen einfach die augen davor
wir könnten die migration über das
mittelmeer beenden wenn sie bereit wären
mit italien und anderen
mittelmeeranrainern dafür zu sorgen dass
keiner mehr illegal übers meer nach
europa gelangen kann
stattdessen
was wird gemacht stattdessen ermuntern
sie die humanitären schleuser und
menschenhändler auch ngo s genannt
lassen deren illegal eingeschleusten
passagiere noch nach deutschland
einfliegen und wollen sogar noch einen
staatlichen wassertaxi dienst einrichten
das ist wirklich nur noch protest sehr
geehrte damen und herren eine wirksame
sicherung und kontrolle der grenzen ist
möglich die kosten würden sich jährlich
im einstelligen milliardenbereich
bewegen und das wissen sie kein
vergleich mit den ökonomischen
politischen und vor allem
gesellschaftlichen folgekosten der
anhaltenden ungeregelten einwanderung
sie wollen millionen bürger durch
verbote strafsteuern und dirigistische
maßnahmen in ihrer individuellen
mobilität einschränken aber illegale
einwanderer können sich weiter frei und
ungehindert über unsere grenzen bewegen
selbst wenn die asyl täuschung aufliegt
und der aufenthaltstitel verweigert wird
müssen sie kaum eine abschiebung führen
sie haben das geld für die abseitigen
partikularinteressen übrig aber nicht
für die effektive kontrolle unserer
grenzen und den schutz unserer bürger
die ihnen einen rekord anteil des von
ihnen erwirtschafteten einkommens
überlassen müssen die gegenleistung
bleiben sie schuldig inzwischen
inzwischen hat jeder zweite hartz 4
empfänger einen migrationshintergrund
dazu kommt fast zwei drittel der
sogenannten flüchtlinge leben von hartz
iv
also zwei drittel ihrer fachkräfte leben
von hartz iv
asül zuwanderer sind übrigens
überproportional kriminalitäts belastet
gemessen am bevölkerungsanteil schweren
sexual- und tötungsdelikte durch
zuwanderer haben erschreckend zugenommen
das lagebild zuwanderungs kriminalität
des bundeskriminalamtes bestätigt dass
doch schwarz auf weiß hören sie doch
auch hier um zu brüllen
das für die bürger die sicherheit im
öffentlichen raum mehr und mehr verloren
geht lässt sie offenkundig gleichgültig
man sieht dass hier eine ältere hypothek
ist das gescheiterte experiment zehn
jahre euro rettung durch verlorene
hilfskredite und geldschöpfung auf
knopfdruck sind zehn jahre umverteilung
von unten nach oben und vom bürger zum
staat
die nullzinspolitik über die sich olaf
scholz ja gestern so gefreut hat führt
die deutsche mittelschicht und den
sparer ins prekariat das märchen vom
reichen land stimmt schon lange nicht
mehr in europa belegen die deutschen bei
vermögen den letzten platz
wenn die draghi blase platzt zündet der
euro geld sozialismus das wissen wir
der anteil der faulen kredite in den
bilanzen südeuropäischer banken die
summen die im feuer stehen ist
gigantisch das kartenhaus der zombie
banken steht auf dem wackligen boden der
negativ zinspolitik der ezb und die
zerstört unaufhaltsam
das geschäftsmodell der soliden banken
wir stehen vor einem gigantischen
bankencrash sehr geehrte damen und
herren wir werden
bei gleichbleibender entwicklung eine
staatsschulden und bankenkrise erleben
hyperinflation und anschließender
währungsreform bei der die menschen
alles verlieren werden und sie sagen es
ihnen nicht was tun sie um das zu
verhindern natürlich gar nichts im
gegenteil sie befeuern die entwicklung
auch noch von ezb-chef im christine
lagarde irgendwie dafür beifall und ganz
viel um arme von jener frau die 2010 als
iwf-direktorin erklärte ich zitiere hier
müssen die eu verträge brechen um den
euro zu retten zitat ende
und das ist genau ihr verständnis von
rechts treue für eine andere als eine
lösung zum deutschen nachteil hätten sie
aber vermutlich auch gar keine
mehrheiten zusammenzukommen
denn sie haben in deutschland in europa
haben sie sich isoliert und niemand
nimmt sie mehr erst bei internationalen
konferenzen sitzen sie im abseits
während die anderen ihre interessen
verfolgen und auch durchsetzen sie haben
das verhältnis zu den usa zerrüttet die
briten aus der eu getrieben und thun im
kielwasser der franzosen nichts für eine
vernünftige praxislösung und jetzt legen
sie uns einen haushalt vor der vor allem
eins erkennen lässt dass sie und ihr
kabinett nicht verstanden haben was die
stunde geschlagen hat sie verkonsumieren
die immer noch reichlich kassierten
steuergelder als würde der segen ewig
weiter fließen was wenn die
geburtenstarken jahrgänge die jetzt auf
dem höhepunkt ihrer beruflichen laufbahn
sind in zehn jahren in rente gehen und
nicht mehr bis zum anschlag geborgen
werden können was passiert denn dann
vorsorge für schlechte zeiten ist in
diesem haushalt ein fremdwort der
investitionsanteil ist trotz des rekord
volumens lächerlich niedrig und
akrobatisch schöngerechnet und dazu
verdient es auch absolut absurd der
bundesfinanzen
ja sogar noch an schulden machen weil
anleger für langlaufende anleihen
negativ renditen zahlen
das allein zeigt wie das geldsystem aus
den fugen geratene sehr geehrte damen
und herren denn es sind die bürger die
durch negativzinsen wie durch eine
sondersteuer kalt und gnadenlos
enteignet werden es ist das geld der
bürger direkt und indirekt eingetrieben
dass sie verschleuderten der ökonom
daniel stelter berechnet ich zitiere
alleine auf bundesebene wurden in den
letzten zehn jahren 460 milliarden euro
zusätzlich verfügbares geld für konsum
und wahlgeschenke verplempert zitat ende
dabei gibt es genug baustellen im land
in dem das geld der bürger besser und
sinnvoller ausgegeben werden könnte
die infrastruktur verfällt straßen
verkommen schulgebäude verfallen die
bahn funktioniert immer schlechter
schnelles internet gibt es anderswo von
großprojekten wie flughäfen die nie
fertig werden gar nicht zu reden
die sozialsysteme sind überlastet und
nicht zukunftsfähig
deutschland droht eine massive
altersarmut die öffentliche ordnung
leidet sicherheit geht verloren ist dass
die grünen nicht interessiert das weiß
ich die bundeswehr ist kaum noch
einsatzfähig die arbeitende bevölkerung
ist mit hohen steuern und abgaben
belastet
und statt den bürger das zuviel
abgenommen geld zurückzugeben nicht
einmal den soli können sie rechtskonform
abschaffen brütet ihre regierung und die
sie tragenden parteien schon über die
neuen steuern co2 steuer vermögenssteuer
sonderabgaben auf alles mögliche jeder
vorwand scheint ihnen recht um die
bürger immer weiter zu belasten weil sie
mit dem überreichlich vorhandenen
steuergeld doch gar nicht umgehen können
das ist doch die wahrheit hier
und so kann es einfach nicht weitergehen
ein grundsätzliches umdenken tut not
umwelt- und ressourcenschonung statt
klimaschutz schluss mit der kopflosen
energiewende stopp der unkontrollierten
einwanderung und sicherung unserer
grenzen abkehr von der euro
inflationspolitik und vor allem mehr
freiheit für die bürger und alle die in
diesem land werte schaffen denkt und
redefreiheit stadt diffamierung
andersdenkender die das politische klima
vergiftet wirtschaftliche freiheit statt
gängelungen neue verbote entlastungen
bei steuern und abgaben stadt steuer
bucher bürokratismus und umverteilung
hören sie auf ludwig erhard ich zitiere
kamera du starrt dich nicht um meine
angelegenheiten sondern geht mir so viel
freiheit und lasst mir vom ertrag meiner
arbeit so viel dass ich meine existenz
und mein schicksal und dasjenige meiner
familie selbst zu gestalten in der lage
bin
zitat ende das ist freiheitliche
bürgerliche politik die unser land so
dringend nötig hat und die in dieser
regierung keine heimat und keinen
fürsprecher mehr hat ich bedanke mich
[Applaus]